[Aplausos]
sí
una vez los años no pisaron
bueno
y tampoco lo voy a hacer
pero lo que sí quiero es que por un
minuto ahí cómodamente como están en sus
asientos disfruten esta oportunidad que
nos damos para estar para compartir para
convivir por favor por un proyecto
solamente
en sus ojos cómodamente por supuesto
tranquilo
pero no pasa nada están en su casa
después de nada
siempre con respiración tiempo a
ocurrirnos cómodamente y sobre todo muy
protegida
y al andén
siente tu respiración
y compartiendo todos están disfrutando
y así como realmente como esta
respiración
escuche este corazón
siempre tu corazón
y siente lo bien que se siente estrechar
tu corazón siente el ambiente se siente
sentirlo
el ritmo
como con cada acción
y paraguay
y observa en tu corazón tiene una puerta
y en el corazón
y ahí dentro de tu corazón te vas a
encontrar
tranquilo
ya que mientras se aproxima
y desde baterías
y ahora por favor tú para que frente a
texto interno y la corrección
a tus miradas el cabello tu boca te
reconoces
por favor si lo que te va a decir
inglés
sintiendo
y ahora tu reflejo tú eres parte y yo te
acepto como
tú eres parte de mi asunto tal y como tú
eres y siempre siempre tú estarás
conmigo
mientras ustedes
y así muy cómodamente como estas después
de esto cada una de las partes
[Música]
guarda esta sensación de paz de
bienestar que tú ya tienes en tu mente y
de corazón
pero regresando aquí y ahora es una
respiración diferente cuando todas
establecidas
a de cv
todo bien todo bien
la imaginación es una gran fuerza creada
y cuando se mezcla con su tía se
convierte en un arma
muy poderes
es decir
y desde muy pequeño aprendí a vivir
conmigo
con el talento la creatina
y la disciplina
el talento y la creatividad por parte de
mi madre
porque a pesar de recibir muy escaso
presupuesto siempre tuvo lenguas que no
son suficiente para darnos un plato de
comida caliente a todos
y la disciplina por parte de mi padre
porque a pesar de que trabajó por más de
30 en los nacionales
un padre siempre dijo
sólo los que estudian su primo
y me pasaron más de 40 años de mi vida
y aquí está
aprendí disfrutando con todos ustedes
pero bueno es donde el objetivo
tener un título y trabajar
y trabajar
a tener hijos en trabajar
y ésta
estando en otro canal con la luz en una
viviendo disfrutando día a día su vida
sin mayor con salida que solamente
vivido
provocando con ello muchas veces que se
note un poco que se desperdicie también
que se pierda su proyecto
uno de nuestros motivos cuando vemos que
tienes que aparecemos en nuestros padres
doctor químico arquitecto maestro
licenciada nuestra doctora
como tú le preguntas a tus hijos cuando
te quiere
y yo por ti
porque nuestros hijos lo primero que
están haciendo es separarse de la imagen
paterna separarse
tratando de crear su propia identidad
su propio camino
es así como
si no fuera que estudios recientes nos
están indicando
que son más los jóvenes universitarios
que están
perdió algunos que se están desempeñando
como más universitario e lamentado
muchas veces ver que cordones que tienen
el talento suficiente para lograr
objetivos para alcanzar sus metas para
lograr un sentido de vida
en el desperdicio
es decir
abandona muy baja
suelta para que muchas veces para
seguirlos unos de otros para el banco de
otro
o sea los desperdicios
y en la práctica clínica
me he dado cuenta que esto está
sucediendo principalmente porque no les
estamos enseñando a nuestros hijos
a reconocerse a valorarse a darse cuenta
que tienen todos los recursos necesarios
para ser exitosos e importantes
para que tengan un propósito
si recuerden que lo que comemos pero
sobre todo
lo que quiero y hacia donde quiere
y quiero compartir juntos
descubrimos de la personalidad juvenil
de nuestros jóvenes de nuestros hijos
que nosotros mismos
vamos a llegar a eso que queremos hacer
aquí sino que juntos vayamos
señores señoras
vayamos haciendo lo que está aquí
pero el punto que tenemos que descubrir
de nosotros mismos de la personalidad de
nuestro ser
guantes caliento claro gracias por
anotar los que ya tienen
atentamente
cuál es aquello que puedo hacer sin
esfuerzo
el punto débil
lugar bonita
y
se presente está bien si no no quiero
usar nuestros costes de ahí están
como me decía a mí
[Aplausos]
maravilloso lo prendo la primera no hay
una oportunidad muy importante que
encontraron en un sobre buscar algo que
sea productivo para ti y luego repasó
pero ellos
estudió ahí están todos y cada uno
el segundo punto
con la estación
qué es aquello que te comprometes
300 teniendo con él
te acuestas con él
ocupación estudios para ti
y tengo talento
quizás si es que puedo hacer aquí
importa que esté cansado la situación
porque me gusta lo quiero lo disfruto es
algo que me encanta y no importa la hora
no importa el tiempo no importa el
momento no quiero seguir así
en esta ocasión lo que me gusta hacer y
el fuerte punto es
tu creatividad
con esta claridad que es útil
con esta primera mano
de triana
pero sobre todo de retirarte
de reinventarse
portunidad y saber que tiene
en el momento que así lo deseas puedes
volver a reinar o inventarte y recrear
las uñas
alarte sueño
sin fantasía
y si ya te ves
acción
lo que más me gusta hacer la creatividad
y si todo esto lo aderezamos con
disciplina nos va a dar una fórmula que
caliente vacaciones
disciplina es igual
es igual
éxito no podemos fallar
solamente necesitas
deseando
el talento es una manifestación de
nuestro
inteligencia emocional y desaliento
tiene esta actividad
el talento de hacer la diferencia entre
señor y lograr que solo
es así
el que va a hacer que tengas un
propósito de vida
cuando usted desea
pero jóvenes no es un compromiso contigo
con tu disciplina explicación
con tu creatividad
computado a desarrollar
que pueda ser seguía avanzando
el sentido de vida y el propósito de mí
una
pero
escuchamos la palabra
y
únicamente si no tienen una serie de
prensas militantes
hasta temblamos
y su cierre
pero sabes
en tu talento en tu creatividad
anterior entonces increíblemente
responsabilidad
no usan por lo que quieres
disfrutando lo que haces y teniendo
claro por qué lo haces sin perder el
rumbo
y disfruta lo que hace
pero no recordar
el talento hará la diferencia entre
escenas y lograr que sea
recuerden que el talento no es un regalo
que recibieron y ya lo notarán el
talento es algo que tienes parada
sí
[Aplausos]